yo with a mic on i don't think that
dudes could [ __ ] with me any
day of the week any second of the day
like yeah yeah yeah brother dudes i'm
telling you
yeah i used to listen to joe's podcast i
used to tell myself bro every time
i'm like could you have them clown stop
chiming in when you're game yeah
sometimes you speaking i know you you're
already [ __ ] where you spinning tell
them clowns to shut the [ __ ] up
yeah yeah yeah dudes getting forty
thousand dollars a year man shut up
nobody wanna hear you talking about like
like you're really breaking down the
break shut up you know what i mean
shut the [ __ ] up like joke could talk
about it
now he would make more sense because he
was sweating that bummer has [ __ ]
he thought they thought it was cool
i hope you charge the bum ass [ __ ]
twice like double the rate they're dumb
and [ __ ]
you got to do it you got to do it yo do
you think joe felt
guilty when they would defend him
swindling them
like do you think there's ever a part of
him on the podcast when he was like man
i got these [ __ ] wrapped around
my pinky bro
um i'm gonna be honest i i've and i
still think he probably feels this way
and i feel this way too yeah
like are you really robbing somebody
like
all right you you guys do flagrant two
and in the primary host of
kash you're right everybody has a piece
of this podcast okay but but here's the
thing
if you thought man i'm carrying these
[ __ ] like right lebron
like remember that remember that uh
horrible cavs team he
wrote like the finals yeah
if you feel you carrying these dudes
you're probably looking at them like
you should be working at walmart right
right like bro i'm over so
what i'm hearing joe talk about it he's
like yo they're getting paid like a
hundred thousand dollars these dudes are
problems
that's what he's thinking like he's not
thinking like we created this
i think maybe his audience is probably
trying to show him like no
it's not just you we actually did like
well we're being honest doesn't that
mean that they
they like them and that they resonate
with them like if we're going to give
rory more all the credit they deserve
if people are going to listen to a
podcast how about this if six months
from now people are still listening at
these numbers
don't you got to say all right you got
something maybe you don't understand it
i'll also say that people do when you
say they can't they're not as good
as me and for you to say to that point
for you to say
they're not as good as me you're
incredible at this like i'm already
seeing like you can carry [ __ ] on your
own in a way
not a lot of people can so to say there
there's no way they're as good as me
cool but you're a top whatever whatever
what a point one point zero zero one
percent
so they can still be good and not be as
good as you all right
as andrew said you want me to be logical
or just
emotional we do a thing here called
feelings no facts
no no honestly um i'm gonna be logical
with this one all right
i actually like they do have their worth
in i do think the audience loves all
three of them together
but they had good chemistry yeah but i
still think
and this is this is one of the reasons
why you know
i in 2017 when i got on everyday
struggle yeah
like you know i was doing my youtube
thing and you know i i felt i was really
good on
good on that you know platform but i've
never really been on camera
i never really like you were awkward at
first and that's what you learned how to
be good
exactly yeah and i looked at that
and joe was a [ __ ] pro from day one
yeah he was a pro
and when i was even thinking about these
dudes is like
you don't as much of an [ __ ] he is
you don't know the benefit
and the luxury you have working with
someone like
if you when you work with charlemagne
very early on yeah when someone could do
some heavy lifting and do some things
that maybe you weren't
you're not there yet with i'm not here
without charlemagne and i don't mean
that in terms of like
the access to people i mean that in
terms of the access to skill
yeah it's like [ __ ] are playing
europe and then they come to the nba you
learn how to play basketball in the nba
remember this
there's a reason why luca doncic goes
back to slovenia
and that team makes the olympics for the
first time i think in their country's
history
it's because luke has been playing in
the nba charlemagne says i'm a
professional talker and that
[ __ ]
is so good at talking and you gotta rise
your [ __ ] to that and i wasn't even
close
when we first started it was something i
got to get better at every single time
and see how good he was and try to pick
up a little bit of that every single
time yeah
yeah and i hear you and that's what i'm
saying well it's a sink or swim moment
but you can't evaluate over the first
six months
they have to show if they could end up
being what you are i'll say this i'll
say this this is what i'll give them
credit so what i admire about them is a
lot of people
wouldn't take that chance they took the
chance to fail
and if i'm being honest well no a lot of
people would go all right let me try to
get another job let me do some a r [ __ ]
let me do something else in music
maybe there's opportunities they could
have got and this way they couldn't fail
in front of
all the people right that that are
looking at them going can you carry a
show
now they said [ __ ] it we're gonna go do
it we're gonna prove that we were
a valuable asset to joe's podcast and
in six months or a year we'll see if
they are but i admire them taking a
chance a lot of [ __ ] don't take
the chance they sit on the sidelines
they [ __ ] they complain they whine they
don't do [ __ ]
i admire that mm-hmm it's not even hate
it's actually a little bit of hate a lot
of logic
all right joe budden
there's your boone is i might call him
he has a
podcast number correct mm-hmm kinda
all right
before we get there before we get there
son if rory or maul got a bad deal think
how bad the deal on the joe budden
network is no hold on
wait wait wait wait wait no no no no no
think about this though you're getting
spotified out that [ __ ]
and this is why i realized people are
blinded by their need to have sympathy
for these dudes
more than actually being objective right
yeah i was on that
i was on joe budden podcast for four
years why i never did nothing on the
side
you you brought up a great point why i
never did why i never did this before
why didn't this kiss y'all doing skits
did joe have y'all really locked in the
basement
right really victimizing y'all like like
this was like the r kelly show where
like
apparently kelly got people like they
got look at the walls like i couldn't do
anything
yeah i always thought they had some type
of deal where they couldn't do anything
else
because i've been inviting myself yeah i
want to have a conversation
we could get on a platform you could
even be your [ __ ] yeah but no joke
get joe out of it i don't want your
daddy here okay yeah yeah yeah
and they never did it now they're forced
to sink or swim
everybody's giving them the credit
saying oh my god they had to do it
why didn't they do it before they didn't
have to though they didn't have to end
with that what will they be doing they
didn't have to end i'll be honest it's
not this they would have to go back to
them
they could have sunk you got to give
them credit they're swimming but
they're swimming because of the
disappointment of joe but they're trying
to swim
you know just because it happened out of
desperation
where like if they truly felt like they
were partners in this thing
and they want to give their everything
to it because they truly felt their
partners
i'm not mad at that at all like i think
that that's admirable
everybody's sacrificing their personal
desires to
build the band right like you look at
that band queen
you know bohemian rap city that song and
that kind of [ __ ] it's like that one
the lead singer queen he got the deal to
go do the album by himself and then when
he was writing it out by himself he was
like
man this [ __ ] ain't as fun i like being
with the boys
and yeah i'm the [ __ ] lead singer but
it's more fun the thing that we built
with the boys so if you want to put
everything into that i don't knock you
for that
i understand where you're coming from in
terms of leverage but if you truly
believe that you're a family
i'm surprised you're you're even making
this point just because of this
being someone that i've seen you do a
million skits
this is outside of brilliant idiots yeah
i've seen you do so many [ __ ] on youtube
on other shows yeah i see you go to like
it wasn't even mtv with some other [ __ ]
was actually i don't know what
it was some [ __ ] [ __ ] thing
that [ __ ] was yeah yeah but i've seen
you do so much
i've always thought of it like this and
i'm pretty sure you thought of it like
this
yeah i'm gonna do things outside of this
hopefully to bring it back to the
squad 100 and when you look at it
brother dudes was just showing up to a
job they never ever try to promote it
outside of that
they weren't hustling and trying to make
the joke podcast bigger when there was
a pressure i needed to maybe for spotify
joe had to do it so i had to do all the
legwork of course i'm gonna look at you
like a worker when
i'm the only one doing all these extra
[ __ ] yeah is that not fair
yeah no no i think it's a reasonable
argument alex come on now
i know i know you getting paid but come
on bro i'm saying it's a reasonable
argument but
i don't know what they were doing behind
the scenes like they have stuff going on
outside of just the podcast so you can't
say that they're not doing anything
i'm just saying by them growing their
awareness like
in their public persona it also brings
eyes to the show
but he's saying they weren't doing
anything to grow that they never did
that
i mean they all had something they did i
don't know a decent follow-up
here's the thing there's two ways to go
about it one way is use the opportunity
you have
and then deliver the best content the
best material like i remember
when brilliant idiots was the only thing
i had right i'm
researching i'm getting ready to have my
[ __ ] argument
i'm looking at all these videos i'm
reading i'm making sure that i can be
the best that i could be
90 [ __ ] we didn't even touch but just in
case we touched it
i want to be ready to go
you